Look at this place and all the possibilities
hello peter do i know you this christmas they're
a danger to our universe spider-man's
greatest enemies are unleashed in imax
what's happening they're starting to
come through and i can't stop them
Welcome back everyone this will be my new
spider-man no way home video they dropped some new
trailer footage there's more tobey maguire andrew
garfield easter eggs so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel we're doing a
giveaway for imax tickets for the movie all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber and just
leave all your predictions for the movie in the
comments so i'll just start with the new footage
then i'll talk about the new tobey maguire andrew
garfield easter eggs that some of you may have
spotted there's people posting about it all over
social media this morning during the new footage
you see more that early part of the movie where
spider-man has mj and it seems like they're being
chased by the nypd like you see spider-man's
picture here on the billboard here from mysterio's
video early theory about what's happening here in
this part of the movie it seems like it picks
up right after the spider-man far from home
post-credits scene like if you notice mj's outfit
here it's the exact same outfit she was wearing
in the spider-man far from home post-credits
scene so charting the timeline of the movie it
seems like what happens is is they actually
see mysterio's video he doxxes spider-man,
outs his identity to the world jay jonah jameson
broadcast this video he and mj seem like they
totally freak out and then he just quickly
tries to take her back to queens and that's
what we're watching here we see him web slinging
with her through all the buildings yelling about
her father i thought your father liked me well
not anymore where are we going i don't know your
house oh my god okay i thought you said your
dad really liked me no well not anymore dude
dude then they get trapped on top of
the queensborough bridge here you see
the nypd helicopter and they jump into the subway
tunnels to try and escape so that seems like it's
happening right at the beginning of the movie and
is basically like right after spider-man far from
home ends then early theory he tries to change
back into his regular clothes and go to school
the next day and hope that nobody saw mysterio's
video but you see like all the kids in school here
pull their phones out and start taking videos of
him to post on their social media accounts so at
some point during the day he probably figures
out no everybody saw this everybody's going to
be bugging me about this so they just head to
the rooftop and you see the newspaper with his
picture all over it and that joke about the spider
minions about him controlling mj at ned leeds
and then that crowd is waiting for him outside the
school just yelling about him with all those signs
and then eventually the police show up at all
their homes and haul them in for questioning
and that's where he gets the idea to
go to doctor strange to perform the
spell like could you please make it so
that mysterio never outed my identity
this scene of doctor strange is going crazy
with all the tears and reality behind him
trying to fix this spell seems like it's happening
at the beginning of the movie the first time he
attempts the spell to make everyone forget and
then spider-man messes it up it seems like this is
him trying to fix everything like while the spell
is happening spider-man messes up all of reality
just explodes around them you can see these purple
tears they look like the purple tears at the end
of the movie too around the statue of liberty
in the sky and when he's fixing everything here
it seems like he just collapses everything like
everything that gets messed up and just shoves
it into this magic box with the symbol of agamotto
on it or actually it's the symbol of the fishanti
it's the same symbol that's in the window of the
sanctum that's why later in the statue of liberty
scene where you see this giant ring exploding it
seems like it's the box exploding like whatever
it was the doctor strange fix the sinister six do
something to cause the box to explode and that's
probably what causes all these giant purple tears
in reality around them there's a newer scene of
electro inside this building just looking through
the blinds wearing a jacket talking about all the
possibilities that he sees for himself in this new
mcu universe it confirms some of the early leaks
more on that in a second with the andrew garfield
spider-man easter eggs but him in this building
might be connected to what's going on with him
fighting doctor octopus inside this high rise here
like early theory doctor octopus is only a villain
in the movie for a hot minute during the early
bridge fight here when they first come through
to the mcu dimension we get more new footage of
him too in this bridge fight with him spinning
spider-man around with his octopus tentacles
early theory once they start talking it through
because doctor octopus is a genius in his own
right in his field they figure out that all of
reality is going to collapse unless they fix
everything in just maintaining doctor octopus's
hero redemption arc from spider-man 2 doctor
octopus agrees to help them reluctantly do you
know peter parker who's spider-man yes is that him
no is that him no is that him no is that him no is
that him no is that him yes it seems like doctor
octopus helps spider-man fight them and maybe
big maybe he winds up being killed by electro
or the other villains i don't think that all these
versions of the sinister six characters from the
tobey maguire spider-man movies and the andrew
garfield spider-man movies are going to survive
through the end of the film like some of these
sinister six characters will probably get killed
off or they'll send some of them successfully
back to their original universes which will
kind of effectively kill them anyway the other
piece of evidence was in that amy pascal interview
that i did a video for a couple days ago she did
a interview recently where she spelled all these
beans about the next spider-man trilogy of movies
and what they're planning for the story of that
but during that she also said part of the reason
for doing all these tobey maguire andrew garfield
spider-man things including their villains in the
movie was to put a bow on 20 years of spider-man
films don't you feel old now it's been almost 20
years since tobey maguire's first spider-man movie
that feels weird but i'll allow it but they
wanted to do this huge one-time celebration
to just show how far things have come so that's
why they're bringing all the old stuff back
for this movie they are still planning on making
more sinister six spin-off movies like we know
about the new craven movie with aaron taylor
johnson i can't wait for all the quicksilver
memes you did not see that coming spider-man but
i think most of those new sinister six movies
that sony is planning will trade more heavily
on the newer versions of the characters and
totally new villains like craven the hunter for
instance michael keaton's vulture in the morbius
trailer is supposed to try and recruit him for a
new team that he's putting together control hey
dr mike tyler doing the whole good guy thing
huh what's up doc maybe i should stay in touch
but it's meant to be this big sinister six
teaser and he's probably not talking about this
version of the team we see in spider-man no way
home and really when you think about it in spite
of me in no way home it's more like the sinister
four because doctor octopus seems like he helps
spider-man and doctor strange it's just they're
trading heavily on sinister six easter eggs and
tropes so let me know in the comments which
tobey maguire and andrew garfield sinister six
characters do you think will come back again
in future movies there's another new scene of
spider-man vs doctor strange when doctor strange
tries to trap him inside the mirror universe to
keep him from getting away with a special box
that they used to send the sinister six villains
back to their original universes and even though
they're fighting just to be clear i think most
people have figured this out it's really more of
a moral argument spider-man is trying to have with
him because he wants to find another way to fix
things without having to kill the villains because
that's basically what sending them back would do
the other really funny tobey maguire and andrew
garfield easter eggs some of you spotted came from
one of the tie-in games from the movie so marvel
contest of champions does this a lot of times for
movies they actually have a new spider-man no way
home integration where they did some side missions
where they're phonetically teasing tobey maguire
and andrew garfield in these new side quests these
always go through multiple levels of approval at
marvel so somebody in marvel is clearly having a
lot of fun with this zoom and enhance these three
chapters are the teasers and some of you have
probably spotted what it is that they're doing
here so chapter one to be or not to be is a play
on tobey maguire's name the villains are green
goblin doctor octopus tobey maguire spider-man
villains chapter two is andrew the day is a play
on andrew garfield's name the villains are rhino
and electro andrew garfield spider-man villains
in chapter three is tomfoolery which is a play
on tom holland's name and it takes a long time
to program design this and get approval from
it from marvel because all this does have
to be approved by people at marvel so it's not
like they just did this two days ago on the fly
i just did a video about how sony also officially
started leaning into all the tobey maguire andrew
garfield jokes with their latest official promos
for the movie like full-blown big time official
promos they actually had tom holland reference
tobey maguire and andrew garfield on the last one
this is now spider monday and to celebrate i have
a really big announcement but first let me bring
in two very special friends to help out i mean
it's only right we are your best friends right
it makes sense for us to join this announcement of
course i mean who else would it be which other two
very special people could he possibly be talking
about indeed just expect them to do more of this
as we get closer to the film coming out but i
don't think that they're actually intentionally
going to include any real big footage of them in
any of the trailers not counting all the weird
edits where it seems like they did a bad job
of trying to cover them up like the mysterious
floating andrew garfield hands in the phantom
punches that's not something that they did on
purpose but if you have spotted any other funny
tobey maguire or andrew garfield easter eggs in
the promos or things that it seems like it slipped
through like they didn't spot they didn't remove
just include those in the comments below i'm
working on a big hawkeye episode 4 elena bulova
trailer video they finally released some official
footage of elena bulova going after hawkeye in
the future episodes so make sure you have alerts
enabled for my channel so you don't miss that and
congratulations to the giveaway winner from my
last big spider-man video josiah allen please
email me on the about page of my channel so i can
get your contact details and everyone click here
for my full hawkeye episode 3 video with daredevil
and kingpin easter eggs and click here for my last
big spider-man no way home video and learn what's
going on during that new trilogy of spider-man
movies thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!